[Musique]
bonjour à toutes et à tous et bienvenue
pour cette foire aux questions foire aux
questions pour laquelle j'accueille
aujourd'hui le professeur florentin
maurras de l'université internationale
de floride à miami donc florentin un bon
jour au jour donc vous êtes géologue
sédimentologue sédimentologue oui vous
avez certainement vu passer chers
auditeurs delà cette publication très
récente à propos de l'extinction crétacé
tertiaire comme on l'appelle encore en
france on devrait l'appeler crétacé
paléogène donc dans cet article les
auteurs décrivent une couche géologique
qui contiendrait finalement des restes
qui auraient été déposés directement
après l'impact de météorites qui a causé
cette crise crée crétacé tertiaire et
donc qui serait finalement un
enregistrement direct des conséquences
de la chute de la météorite et notamment
l être cette couche serait très riche en
fossiles et donc nous raconterait
beaucoup de choses quant à l'extinction
des dinosaures du mois c'est ce qu'en
dit la presse
c'est ce qu'en dit la presse sur et sur
internet
donc aujourd'hui j'ai l'honneur
d'accueillir donc comme je le disais
florentin maurras qui est l'un des co
auteurs de cet article donc qui va
pouvoir nous parler directement nous
donner un avis finalement de première
main sur ces sur cet article
donc c'est un très grand honneur pour
moi de vous accueillir
c'est un article qui a qui a finalement
générait beaucoup de scepticisme déjà il
a été un peu victime de sa date de
parution puisque c'est un article qui
parle beaucoup de poissons et qui est
sorti le 1er avril donc déjà c'était pas
de chance donc il ya eu beaucoup de les
gens l'ont regardé immédiatement d'un
oeil sceptique
bon et puis à chaque fois que le à
chaque fois que le thème est comme ça
très très sexy très très intéressant
évidemment le scepticisme les est
d'autant plus fort du coup avec le
professeur maurras on va essayer un peu
de remettre tout ça à plat et parler du
contenu scientifique dont déjà est ce
que est ce que vous pourriez nous faire
un peu a résumé de cette découverte
un résumé de cet article du quel a été
votre contribution
d'accord bonjour benoît et les auditeurs
ma contribution je suis ainsi dimanche
auront donc je ne suis pas allée entre
leurs deux dinosaures c'est monsieur de
parma qui a fait ses études sur un
dinosaure l'évidence qu'on a c'est très
simple la couche qui est qui représente
l'événement de l'impact est un mélange
de sédiments marais et de sédiments
terrestre et c'est à 2000 km de la côte
donc il est évident que le droit d'avoir
une vague extraordinaire qui a dû
mélanger des éléments de la mer profonde
et des éléments de la terre donc c'est
l'évidence
et nous avons aussi la structure et
structures sont définitivement des
structures de vagues qui saura les deux
de la côte à 2 à l'intérieur et de
l'intérieur a la cote
c'est ce qu'on appelle des ventes
d'oscillations ses 22 6 nations ne sont
pas communes donc c'est l'évidence que
nous avons qui a eu ce qu'on appelle
sèche
la différence c'est que quand vous avez
un tsunami
les dépôts il présente des structures
qui vont dans une vie
action permanente une seule direction
alors que dans le sèche qu'on appelle
une vague d'oscillations les éléments
ils vont dans deux directions
parce que la vague va dans une direction
un certain moment ils savent à la
loterie direction à l'autre mais dans
ces colonnes sèches
si je peux me permettre je tenter une
comparaison c'est un peu comme ans comme
quand on secoue un saladier en fait
exact d'accord si on met de l'eau dans
un saladier qu on le secoue la vague va
d'un côté à l'autre n'est un côté à
l'autre
exactement et puis les sédiments qui se
dépose vous montre exactement ce
mouvement de va-et-vient d'accord donc
cette sèche aurait amené des éléments de
la mer directement dans des sédiments
terrestre et du coup ce qui aurait formé
cette sèche c'est l'impact de chicxulub
gtx holloway parce qu'on a des ammonites
aussi des ammonites n'habite pas à
l'intérieur des deux du continent petit
mode typiquement le maire profonde
d'accord donc à 2000 km de la paléo côte
donc de la côte telle qu'elle était au
crétacé on a ces éléments marins qui
n'ont rien à faire là quoi c'est ça le
exactement d'accord alors est comment
est ce que vous avez réussi à dire que
cet événement cette sèche étaient issus
de l'impact de chicxulub et pas d'un
tremblement de terre en fait qu'elle
conclut on à l'évidence avec ce qu'on
appelle la microtechnique les be
connected
si les petites bulles de glace qui se
rendent en qui retombe avec la pac et
ses micros techniques ont été retrouvés
dans l'est avec les poissons
au même moment il faut que ces poissons
et était au même moment de l'impact
parce que ces petites bulles de glace
aurait été déposée au fond de la mer non
pas dans l'est avec les poissons eux
mêmes oui ce que vous dites dans
l'article donc c'est que
il ya des microtechniques qui ont été
retrouvées non seulement autour des
poissons mais aussi à l'intérieur des
poissons à l'intérieur exactement quand
il veut inspiré il absorbait ces petites
bulles de glace qui était dans l'eau à
ce moment là d'accord donc ils en ont
dans les branchies c'est ça l'un des
branchies oui d'accord d'accord d'accord
et alors j'imagine que c'est
microtecnica devait être extrêmement
chaudes les poissons il n'était pas déjà
mort quand north que quand ils retombent
évidemment que tu touches le lot ils
deviennent des petites boules de glace
et si c'est assez froid à ce bord là
d'accord les paddle fiche
non c'est ça l'épagneul fichiers exact
il ya deux le fichant français que je
traduise ça ce sont les les spatules r
voilà ce que tu es
ça s'appelle un statut l'air en français
quand c'est un genre de poisson avec un
est tout plat c'est ça exact d'accord
donc donc ses spatules est ronde et ont
des microtechniques dans les branchies
et vous avez aussi trouvé des
microtechniques dans l'ombre c'est ça
donc il ya des microtechniques à la fois
du milieu terrestre et du milieu
aquatique
oui c'est sûr c'est même picot technique
qu'on a trouvé deux nappes et la
presqu'île du sud d'haïti et qu'on ne
trouve qu'on trouve aussi au mexique et
qu'on trouve un peu partout autour des
caraïbes d'accord d'accord donc est
alors généralement ce qu'on associe avec
cet impact c'est les microtechniques
les quartz choqué et d'iridium vous avez
découvertes sur des quads choqué bossuet
vous en avez aussi oui il ya des quoi
choquer aussi et le l'iridium et
l'iridium non c'est pas tellement
évident parce que il ya eu beaucoup de
beaucoup de remaniements latin d'accord
d'accord
donc il ya des du remaniement c'est à
dire qu'est ce qui s'est passé au niveau
du remaniement ou quand il ya des
remaniements évidemment laissé des
animes des animaux qui viennent qui est
qu'il remanie la surface après le dépôt
donc on ne peut pas voir directement ce
qui se passe évidemment et la chose
essentielle c'est que cette équipe ont
été datés radioactifs par radioactivité
est cité
on exact le même âge que les techniques
qu'on trouve un peu partout s'est
associé à l'impact et au niveau
stratigraphie du coup vous êtes vraiment
êtes juste en dessous de l'horizon du
fameux horizons à iridium
comment comment est-ce que ça comment
est-ce que comment est ce que se
présente cette couche au niveau de la
stratigraphie la scintigraphie en
dessous le couac y adhèrent des photos
qui montrent qu'ils adoptent des
empreintes de pas ludique de des
empreintes de dinosaures les pattes de
dinosaures parce que c'était un endroit
assez boureux donc il y avait des
dinosaures dans cet endroit et on a eu
l'impact et l'arrivée de ces vagues qui
ont apporté les sédiments
donc comme je vous le disais les
sédiments ils ont des structures qui
montre définitivement que ce sont des
vagues ne sèche pas les vagues de jazz
de soul m d'accord peut-être une
question aussi que se posent nos
auditeurs c'est quelle épaisseur
finalement fait cette cette couche parce
que c'est vrai qu'on a
non nous apprend beaucoup pas que la
couche cette couche catastrophique de
qui marque l'extinction crétacé
tertiaire
c'est une très fine couche d'argile noir
mais d'après l'article j'ai l'impression
qu'elle fait beaucoup plus que ça en
épaisseur sais c'est un dépôt assez peu
au final os et un départ assez paper
savard et d'un doigt noah si vous allez
au mexique mais mon bixi qu'il ya
beaucoup beaucoup de dunes de dépôt de
succès de cet événement savary parce que
quand les vagues arrivent le
comportement des vins va dépoter bas va
dépendre de la topographie de l'endroit
c'est pourquoi que ça peut varier d'un
endroit à l'autre et dans cet endroit
qu'on aura il ya des dépôts qui sont
presque jusqu'à presque à émettre
d'autres qui sont beaucoup plus loin - q
donc ce serait vraiment
un dépôt assez catastrophique au
finalement qu au nom absolue ya pas de
doute que c'est un dépôt catastrophique
qui à l'évidence non seulement des
structures mais du mélange des fossiles
dans l'article vous dit ça ça se serait
formée en une heure moins d'une heure
c'est ça comment vous par table comment
comment vous calculez ce résultat
comment vous comment vous est venue dire
cela c'est l'arrivée c'est l'arrivée
l'été qui tu as donc il n'ya pas où
elles étaient petites sont retombés
presque instantanément c'est ça ouais ce
qu'elles sont un élément oui et en
coïncidence avec le dépôt de seiche
du coup oui les vagues amène tous ces
éléments de la mer il aime les mélanges
et en même temps les techniques tomber
leur lot qui y voyager d'ailleurs il ya
une question qui vient de me venir
est ce que est ce que vous connaissez
l'histoire de la découverte du site
oui donc comment comment est-ce que le
site de tanis a été découverte de parme
ac
un paléontologue surtout des dinosaures
et ce tant douala le nom le dakota du
nord dakota du sud jusqu'aux landes ya
des dépôts avec beaucoup lu zoo le
dinosaure et d'autres fossiles études il
étudie les verts débris au sort pour sa
thèse de doctorat donc par chance il est
tombé sur sa sitcom pour moi même quand
tu refusais la géologie d'haïti par
chance je suis tombé sur sa maison
je ne cherchais pas la limite crétacé
tertiaire
ces deux supports changent évidemment
refusé la géologie et bebye on tombe
dessus c'est la même chose pour lui
d'accord donc c'est en cherchant des
dinosaures pour sa thèse donc si c'était
vrai sa thèse c'était il ya un moment du
coup une wii d'accord d'accord
et alors du coup maintenant niveau
paléontologique donc il ya beaucoup de
controverses quant à là il ya encore un
article qui était sorti la semaine
dernière et encore plusieurs articles
des semaines précédentes à propos du de
combien de temps cet
crise crétacé-tertiaire à a duré
finalement et combien d'autres
et est ce que les dinosaures et les
autres le reste de la faune s'est éteint
finalement doucement ou est ce qu'ils se
sont éteints soudainement au moment de
cet impact
donc il ya des ja détonnant et des
arguments pour les deux côtés et du coup
qu'est ce que c'est qu'est ce que ce
nouveau dépôt donc ce le dépôt de tanis
nous apprend sur ajoute finalement à ce
débat le dépôt de tanis l'important
c'est de nous montrer que l'événement a
été si extraordinaire qu'on a eu des
vagues de mer qui ont pénétré jusqu'à
l'intérieur de ce qu'on appelle de
weston intéressé ouais c'était c'est une
grande kof qui qui occupait tout
l'intérieur des états unis à cette
époque là et c'est un endroit très très
très peu profond donc ça montre et
l'envergure de cette catastrophe mais
pour dire exactement quand les
dinosaures ont disparu
on ne peut pas qu'on peut pas le faire
jusque sur cette base
évidemment ça a été l'une des causes
quand l'effet que ça a eu chaud sur le
surtout le gros con c'est que vraiment
c'est ce qui a causé la mort des
dinosaures mais pour dire exactement si
les dinosaures ont été tués à ce moment
là c'est presque impossible parce qu'il
ya eu des dinosaures un peu partout
thomas il ya eu des vous avez parlé de
d'ammonites vous avez parlé des poissons
il ya eu des dinosaures découverts dans
cette couche de tanis panne dinosaures
propre humains il ya eu d'autres
vertébrés que monsieur de palma est en
train d'étudier et pas le dinosaure
directement
évidemment les poissons il les a montrés
la salle antique ton qu'on peut le dire
mais les autres il ya un très net
didier yah d'accord donc c'est qu'il ya
de nouvelles informations qui vont venir
au leahy aura beaucoup de nouvelles
informations sur ça c'est que tu es
khider celui le pavé entre rock
autre incident hématologue on a fait on
a déjà fait notre travail on a montré
que très clairement avec les structures
que c'est définitivement une soudure qui
est associé à un mouvement du sèche et
qui donc ne peut s'être formés que que
suite à un événement sismique
d'envergure et en l'occurrence vu qu'il
y à l'été les microtechniques cet
événement sismique d'envergure c'est la
chute de l'astéroïde
absolument parce que ça c'est exactement
la même date
je suis content j'ai réussi à suivre
pourquoi très bien est ce qu'on peut
voir une parce que finalement enfin
encore une fois les nous autres du grand
public quand on visionne visualise cet
astéroïde en train de tomber on
s'imagine des des grandes vagues se
répandant partout dans le monde
est-ce qu'on a des dépôts de
catastrophique comme ça ailleurs qu'en
amérique du nord monsieur
en effet j'ai écrit un article de mon
premier article est apparu dans le
journal science en 1991 on a décrit le
fait que la structure du dépôt en haïti
est vraiment très similaires la
structure qu'on voit à tanis en f
on se demandait est ce qu'il y avait un
seul impact co2 impact parce qu'on voit
des mouvement oscillatoire il ya eu deux
exactement de passer comme ça donc
et j'ai écrit un autre article en 2005
dans le journal de highbury en géorgie
où j'ai décrit ce phénomène en mer
profonde
donc il n'y a pas eu seulement que le
sèche à tanis il ya eu le sech presque
pas tout au monde
donc je vais le paigc assez clair
d'accord mais gasquet donc ça fait
partie des mots clés qu'on va pouvoir
rechercher sur google maintenant c'est
beaucoup lu je vous enverrai cet article
avec plaisir du coup le
vous l'avez trouvé haïti vous l'avez
trouvé en espagne c'est ça regarde un
peu partout la découverte de ces
événements en haïti a été une découverte
créé en 1901 géo lui comme ceux de palma
lui faisait de la géologie en haïti
quand j'ai vu cette couche particulière
si tu es de 1979 je ne n'avais pas
étudié jusque aux environs des années de
les années 80 comme alvarez a publié son
papier en sciences en 1904 80 et ça a
suscité beaucoup d'intérêt il j'ai
publié mon antique en sciences en 1991
et pourquoi que cette découverte a été
critique c'est parce que les techniques
d'haïti ont été les premières techniques
qui sont d'une d'une dimension qui
démontrait que l'impact devait être très
très proche de ce tournoi c'est ce qui a
permis à monsieur yves lebrun ici vous
verrez aussi d'anciens science et le
brun qui a proposé le site de l'impact
devrait être de la région des caraïbes
et ensuite les et un géologue ils ont pu
trouver réfère au mexique avec la
structure qui se trouvait au mexique
mais c'étaient les triptyques d'haïti
camper clubs qui ont permis de faire
cette hypothèse du coup c'est face à une
découverte qui est qui remonte à fin qui
est ça vient de sortir mais finalement
ça remonte à loin
oui évidemment c'est à dire que le dépôt
de tanis comme je vous dis c'est une une
évidence supplémentaire qui montre
l'importance de cet événement à l'époque
mais on en sait un peu partout que ça a
été une chose extraordinaire et ses
autres
ces autres dépôts ils ont des faux cils
aussi où est ce qu'ils sont vraiment
très similaire à tanis la zone de dépôt
la plupart de ces des pensions de merde
profonde
il ya par exemple des pôles haïti ces
deux mères profondes c'est c'est
pourquoi le dépôt des tannes et c'est
pratiquement exceptionnel parce qu'on
n'a pas de céder paul ii mais décrit de
l'intérieur du continent dans
d'opposants doigts c'est presque
pratiquement à nice le seul endroit où
on peut voir ça d'accord et et au vu des
photos les la préservation est vraiment
assez assez exceptionnel exceptionnelle
s'est exclamé est-ce que vous avez une
explication à ça parce que c'est vrai
que moi encore une fois dans ma tête et
j'imagine dans la tête de nos auditeurs
l'impact de météorites cataclysmique ça
aurait dû faire des petits morceaux
mais finalement c'est ces poissons la
nôtre ce qu'on peut voir sur les photos
ils sont magnifiquement préservé
donc est-ce que ce que vous pouvez
commenter un peu là dessus au point de
l'impact tout a été pulvérisé au moins
jusqu'à 80 kilomètres
pulvérisez complètement les poissons que
vous voyez on était dans des endroits
très loin de l'impact lui-même
ils ont été apportées par les courants
associés à ces va être c'est pourquoi
que ces poissons sont très bien
préservés évidemment ce qui arrive quand
une matière organique et recouvert très
rapidement par les sédiments et qui a
pas d'action de bactéries et autres
choses et de l'oxygène
il se préserve c'est ce qu'on appelle la
gâchette at il su préserve très bien
parce qu'il n'ya pas d'oxygène pour
l'air pour les couvrir
c'est pourquoi ces poissons là ils
paraissent comme des poissons qui sont
morts côté de nous il ya quelques années
de cela mais évidemment c'était pas et
directement au point de l'impact parce
que toi été pulvérisé parce que le dépôt
de tanis montre ce qui ce qui s'est
passé dans l'océan mais il faut voir que
aussi sur terre il y avait des incendies
dx des choses extraordinaires du passé
sur herbe même donc tous ces animaux ces
plantes ont été brûlés c'est terrado
c'est sur terre et en même temps en mer
ce qu'on a là c'est sûr tous
qui s'est passé en mer et qui est
arrivée jusque sur sur le continent donc
sur le continent s'étaient c'est quelles
sont les preuves sur le continent de ces
incendies
est-ce qu'on a des dépôts mon dieu ça
fait presque quarante ans que honnête au
canada il ya ya ya des dépôts au canada
auront pu voir très clairement dès ce
qu'on appelle de soute
c'est cela seul un dépôt de cendres ne
dure incendie qu'on peut voir très
clairement il ya au canada on peut voir
ça et même à l'intérieur des états unis
et à au bassin il ya le bassin de ya un
endroit où l'on là un dépôt t-rès avec
cette serre est de descendre de la santé
oh non ça a été ça a été prouvé et les
les japonais aussi ont fait des études
you chimiques qui ont montré qu'il ya eu
des des produits de l'incendié tout ça
était tout ça et ça a été très
clairement démontré un peu partout il ya
eu des incendies extrade et or un peu
partout au monde
cette époque c'est fascinant donc vous
pouvez vraiment faire une reconstruction
il ya beaucoup de reportages qui porte
un titre comme ça genre le dernier jour
des dinosaures mais finalement avant
votre étude
on avait des spéculations rationnel on
va dire une idée de ce qui pouvait se
passer mais on n'avait aucune preuve
donc là ce que vous apportez finalement
c'est la preuve
l'épreuve du scénario du dernier jour
des dinosaures donc qu'est-ce qu'on
aurait lieu du cool impact d'abord long
de sismique qui se propagent les
sphérules qui retombe en même temps
qu'ils déclenchent des incendies qui se
pointe dans les branchies des poissons
et après tout ce tout ce mouvement cette
sèche qui amène tous les poissons morts
sur le sur le rivage à plusieurs
milliers de kilomètres finalement de la
côte
c'est exact dias usa c'est une prouve a
dit c'est une preuve additionnelle ans
pour l'un et on a eu toutes sortes de
preuves aux secousses le problème du
caté ça a été dit ça a été un débat
depuis des années 80 donc on a eu hier
des dizaines et des dizaines et les
dizaines
articles qui ont été publiés un peu par
tout le monde pour montrer les l'a
démontré vraiment qu'on a eu c'est un
pas qu ils les effets de l'impact peu
partout donc le dépôt du tennis nous
apporte une preuve additionnelle sur
l'effet catastrophique de ce thème pas
mais on s'est un peu par tout le monde
cet impact a été catastrophique par
contre ce qu'on a à l'épreuve un peu
partout que ce soit en europe ou en asie
l'afrique un peu partout on a la preuve
de cet impact et surtout les textiles
qui démontre plus parce que les
techniques ne sont ni ne souffre ne ne
peuvent pas se faire d'un événement
volcanique ça doit être pas un impact
c'est pourquoi les diptyques tir et
point dans les points sans doute nous
avons eu l'impact est aussi évidemment
au mexique là on a le cratère au mexique
ici les dates aussi qui courent ils ont
exactement les mêmes dates mais comme
l'était petit se forme rapidement et
uniquement à cause de l'impact c'est
forcément si on les retrouve dans un
dépôt c'est forcément que le dépôt et
c'est fort mais très vite après l'impact
et comme on les trouve dans les poissons
c'est qu'il ya pas eu de remaniement
exact poisson qui les absorber quand il
y était en gris et à ce moment même
quand la pâte et d'arrivée c'est exact
de moscou était d'accord et ben merci
beaucoup de nous avoir accordé cette
interview
donc je vous souhaite beaucoup de
beaucoup de nouvelles études à propos de
ce gisement de tanis ses grands succès
c'est vraiment une découverte unique qui
nous donne une image pour la première
fois finalement une des preuves
concrètes tout ce scénario de la crise
cat et finalement c'est pas que de la
science-fiction voilà c'est pas que de
la spéculation nationale c'est aussi des
preuves non donc voila merci aussi pour
le la gamme d'accor est une bonne chose
[Musique]
merci de nous avoir écoutés et à très
bientôt sur notre chaîne
[Musique]